réunion de traceurs ce samedi à blois
ils étaient une soixantaine venus de
toute la région a testé le patrimoine
autour du château pour se livrer à leur
sport favori le parcours avec un cas
disons qu après en sautant sur les murs
m'a déjà c'est plus bon pour faire
simple c'est plus amusant mais disons
qu'il ya d'autres raisons par exemple en
sautant sur les murs ça peut nous
permettre d'accéder d'accéder à des
endroits à des points de vue que
personne personne n'a la possibilité
d'avoir en se promenant simplement c'est
à dire en escaladant un petit mur ou en
essayant d'aller tout en haut on peut on
peut visiter différemment on peut avoir
des vues que personne n'a et c'est ce
qui peut être assez intéressant
un événement organisé par l'association
springboks parcours centre avec
initiation pour les plus jeunes et
pratique sportive sur les reliefs de la
ville avec les visiteurs l'idée au
parcours il n'y a pas d'esprit de
compétition
nous sommes tous amis nous sommes le
camarade donc au sel des uns les autres
le principe des événements c'est de
développer la pratique et d'orienter les
personnes vers la station la plus proche
qui pratique le parkour le dynamisme de
l'association de blois fédère les
pratiquants de tous horizons en région
centre val de loire joindre aux mots et
quand y'a pas j'ai pas beaucoup de
l'association vergt romorantin donc du
coup je me suis tourné vers bouaké quand
même plus grande île que romorantin
entre guillemets et surtout parce que
l'association esprit noah qui est
majoritairement attention sort ou là des
acrobaties sont réservés à des athlètes
ou des gymnastes déjà expérimenté